yvette est un comique 11 ans j'aimerais
intégrer les temps devant mondiale cette
jeune tenniswoman d'origine serbe a
débuté le tennis à l'âge de quatre ans
évolue aujourd'hui au tennis-club de buc
sa passion pour ce sport est née en
regardant les matchs de son idole novak
djokovic vainqueur de douze titres du
grand chelem et coupe vite il a des
ailes à un bon service son copain ces
points c'est ses coups droits à servins
et son fort et tout mais on va t'il à
mal et c'est quand même de bien jouer
pour tenter de s'approcher de la
technique du serbe ljubica s'entraîne
deux fois par semaine en double et en
simple pendant 1h30 avec ses coachs la
sportive réalise également des matches
avec son équipe qui évolue en troisième
division des yvelines
je pense qu'elle est assez motivé qu'il
ya des choses qui sont assez prometteuse
chez dans son jeu notamment
voilà son profond qui le coup droit
voilà mon bras et donc voilà il ya des
bonnes choses et j'espère qu'il va
continuer à être motivée parce que dans
une bonne progression en parallèle des
cours de tennis son père dejan ancien
joueur de haut niveau l'aide également
dans sa progression s'entraînant avec
elle plusieurs fois par mois
dans ma famille on n y glane d'amateurs
de tennis moi je jouais quand je nage
entre 15 et 18 ans vivant dans notre
pays d'origine au mexique au poly si les
beats a mis knock il valait plus de mal
donc mais qui est et qui elle joue son
parcours dit comment tirer comme en
place et qu'enfin meurent parce que je
dois me replacer
-plus d'un côté puis de l'autre comme ça
des conseils que you betcha devrait
mettre en application pour réaliser ses
plus grands rêves et pourquoi pas
remporter un jour un tournoi majeur
comme un certain novak djokovic